just one more for
this morning in our Saturday sessions
the folk duo known as the milk carton
kids they've been together since 2011
and will be performing songs from their
new album in just a moment but first I
sat down with the duo and found out
their harmonious folk sound is paired
with a folksy sense of humor the milk
carton kids are Joey Ryan and Kenneth
Patten Gayle brains of the operation and
lead singer a duo who'd pursued separate
solo careers before they connected in
Los Angeles I've done a bunch of things
before meeting Joey whereas he had been
all over the world playing you know sad
small shows for the for the folk
denizens I believe the self deprecation
to me so it's actually self deprecation
well he's gonna I mean I'm a fan of just
normal deprecation sometimes okay but
something happened when they sang
together how would you describe what you
heard for me that the striking thing
about the first time that we played
together even though it was just two
acoustic guitars and two voices singing
together was that it felt complete
physically the way that our our voice is
blended in the air happened in a way
where I just had never had that
experience with another person she
called
[Music]
so patton gail and ryan abandoned their
solo careers
was there any negotiating involved in
this union are you referring to I do 90%
of the work and get 50% of the spoils
I've not haven't represented myself well
but it's folk music there's not much to
split you know the milk carton kids got
a big break right here in what was then
Avatar Studios when producer t-bone
Burnett asked them to be part of another
day another time a concert that
celebrated the music of the Joel and
Ethan Coen film inside Llewyn Davis so
we showed up and we walked into Avatar
Studios for rehearsals and there's Joel
and Ethan and Marcus Mumford and all the
Punch Brothers
and Joan Baez sitting in in studio a
downstairs and we walked in and t-bone
said okay get out your guitars let's see
what song you might play
[Music]
and they've just got this beautiful
footage of us performing the song they
pan over down
[Music]
and there's marcus mumford and a tear
comes down his cheek and then when that
ran on showtime for a long time it made
a big difference in our career and then
the second thing that happened to us was
we were cast in that HBO show vinyl as
England Dan & John Ford Coley you know
you had all their albums I've been in
the history of harmony duo's they did
not get enough credit hey Dan you're
eating the mic again oh man really that
was a good take you
I had a recklessness to it wilds loved
it I had a lot of fun with it we got to
wear moustaches my hair was straightened
the most noteworthy part of that
experience was the day after our episode
aired they canceled the series
[Laughter]